the european union has a great opportunity ahead of it
and also a great
risk the recovery plan agreed
in july 2020 represents a great
opportunity the adoption of
own resources by the 27 and the issuance of the
first 80,000 million bonds this
year by the  commission represent a
gigantic leap in the integration of the union
a decade after the
social democrats proposed the
embryo of a European treasure the states
will borrow for the first time
jointly to achieve an
ecological and digital recovery and help those hardest
hit in the  pandemic now
it is up to the commission to
urgently evaluate the 27 national plans to
guarantee the issuance of 150
billion annually until 2026 and to the
council to approve the first
aid package next July because
there is also a great risk and this
would be the  delay in the implementation
of the plan because any delay that is
imposed now raises
the ashes  of populism if a part
of the population feels abandoned by
this recovery the future of the
youngest will be decided in the outcome of
a revolution is digital and energetic
capable of overcoming the current model of
economic growth prone to
inequality we cannot forget either that
the  The pandemic has hit the most
vulnerable, destroying jobs,
increasing the queues of hunger, and it
has also hit
women the hardest, which is why it is essential
that all national plans
incorporate the gender indicators
agreed upon in Porto, as well as the
social objectives. I hear a lot  to the
right of this chamber to talk about the
reforms obviously we all
agree that we need reforms
but they have to be reforms that address
the strengthening of our welfare state in
order to be able to respond to those who
need it most the commission the council
and this parliament must  make a
firm commitment to take a great leap forward
With a great social pact similar to the one in which
the welfare state after the
Second World War is in our
hands, let us assume our responsibility and
give this great opportunity that
European citizens need, thank you very much